check out this page from the 1998 Sears
Christmas catalog most of the hit video
games that year sold for nearly $70
surely prices have increased since then
especially with high inflation in the
past few years right wrong Ocarina of
Time the big Legend of Zelda release in
Christmas 1998 sold for $70 25 years
later tears of the Kingdom the new Zelda
game also retails for you guessed it
$70 these games are also a lot more
advanced than anything you could get in
1998 no matter how much money you spent
and in Practical terms they're actually
cheaper because Americans make a lot
more money today it now takes the
average worker only about 3 hours to
afford one of these top games compared
to more than 5 hours of work in 1998 if
these prices had kept up with inflation
that $70 game would cost
$125 today thanks to capitalism we're
wealthier and we've got better stuff the
ghosts of Christmas's past must be
pretty jealous of these presents